across europe the signs of a third wave
this is the border between germany and
poland you now need a negative test to
get into germany
and the queues are long
in france new restrictions in paris and
beyond
shops are closing there are strong
echoes here of previous lockdowns
cases are rising fast across continental
europe
driven by what's known as either the
kent or the british variant a rising
tide
that the prime minister worries will
soon reach the uk
on the continent right now you can see
sadly
there is a third wave underway and
people in this country should be
under no illusions that previous
experience
has taught us that that when a wave hits
our friends it i'm afraid uh washes up
on our shores
as well and i expect that we will we
will feel those effects in
in due course if britain and europe now
share a nasty variant
they also share a simmering row over
vaccines
the eu is furious that around 10 million
doses
have been exported from european
factories to the uk
but that none have come in the other
direction
it maintains that astrazeneca has
breached its contract by missing
all its delivery targets tempers are
short
and later this week european leaders
will consider a ban
on vaccine exports this is about making
sure
that companies deliver on
their commitments to the member states
and the european union
that are uh inscribed in um
contracts that they have that they have
with us
hungary approved the use of two more
covid vaccines today
they're not authorized by the european
regulator though and nor is the russian
vaccine sputnik
that's also used in eastern europe the
unity
of the european union is being stretched
in america the astrazeneca vaccine took
a giant step towards official approval
when a trial study declared it's safe
and effective
america has a reported stockpile of
around 30
million doses of this vaccine so far
it has used none adam parsons
sky news